STRATEGY IF ORDERED TO CARRY
OUT A STRIKE.
BRET?
>> Bret: TENSE SITUATION
TONIGHT.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN AT THE
PENTAGON.
JENNIFER, THANK YOU.
MANY LAWMAKERS ARE TONIGHT
PUSHING FOR A SPOT AT THE
DECISION-MAKING TABLE ON
POSSIBLE MILITARY ACTION.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL
TELLS US ABOUT THAT EFFORT
TO GET PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
SEEK NEW PERMISSION FOR A
FIGHT.
>> SOME DEMOCRATS ARE
REITERATING THEIR CALL FOR
CONGRESS TO VOTE ON MILITARY
ACTION IN SYRIA.
>> AS VETERANS WE KNOW OUR
NATION MUST CONSIDER
PURPOSEFULLY AND
DELIBERATELY THE ACTIONS
TAKEN BY OUR MILITARY.
>> THERE IS NOT A CLEAR TASK
THAT WE ARE GIVING TO OUR
TROOPS.
THEY CAN'T TELL US WHERE
THIS IS GOING.
>> BUT HOUSE SPEAKER PAUL
RYAN IS AMONG THOSE
INSISTING PRESIDENT TRUMP
ALREADY HAS THE POWER TO
RESPOND TO ATROCITIES BY THE
SYRIAN REGIME IN
AUTHORIZATIONS FOR THE USE
OF MILITARY FORCE CREATED
AFTER THE 9/11 ATTACKS.
>> WHAT I WOULD HATE TO DO
IN THIS TIME WHEN WE HAVE A
SYMMETRIC THREATS ALL ACROSS
THE GLOBE, PARTICULARLY WITH
ISIS, IS TO HAVE AN AMUF
THAT TIES THE HANDS OF OUR
MILITARY BEHIND THEIR BACKS.
>> DEFENSE SECRETARY JIM
MATTIS ARGUED THE PRESIDENT
WOULD BE JUSTIFIED WITH
2,000 GROUND TROOPS IN SYRIA
TO ACT IN SELF-DEFENSE.
HAWAII HOUSE DEMOCRAT
CHALLENGED MATTIS ON THE
ISSUE.
>> WHILE YOU ARE CORRECT IN
SAYING THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
YET MADE A DECISION, MY
QUESTION IS WILL HE ABIDE BY
THE CONSTITUTION AND COMPLY
WITH THE LAW?
>> I BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WILL CARRY OUT HIS
DUTIES UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION TO PROTECT THE
COUNTRY.
>> A REPUBLICAN MEMBER WHO
IS A MARINE CORPS, IRAQ WAR
VETERAN SAYS CONGRESS SHOULD
DO ITS DUTY.
>> MATTIS MADE IT CLEAR
YESTERDAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T FEEL
THEY NEED THE AUTHORITY.
I DISAGREE.
I THINK THAT'S A MISREADING
OF THE CONSTITUTION WHICH
ONLY GIVES THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH THE AUTHORITY TO
REPEL SUDDEN ATTACKS.
I THINK WE RESTRAIN THE 9/11
AMUF TO ITS BREAKING POINT.
>> A FREQUENT G.O.P. CRITIC
OF THE PRESIDENT GAVE HIM A
LITTLE FLEXIBILITY ON THIS
ISSUE.
>> IT DEPENDS ON THE TYPE OF
ACTION.
IT'S A ONE-OFF MISSILE
STRIKE, YOU CAN ARGUE THAT
IT DOESN'T, BUT ANY
SUSTAINED EFFORT, YES, WOULD
REQUIRE A NEW AMUF.
>> SOME IN CONGRESS DON'T
WANT TO DEBATE AND VOTE ON A
NEW AUTHORIZATION.
IT IS QUITE POSSIBLE THEY
DON'T WANT TO OWN IT IF
THERE ARE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES IN SYRIA.